[Music]
[Music]
another glorious morning
dad always says the pack stays together
that's my girl seat belt mode
now we're searching for a perfect place
to call home
what the heck is that it's the end of
the world
well that's it for me i'm glad it's you
[Music]
chunky
isn't it strange how this food grows in
perfectly straight
genius
i thought cave people died off years ago
we
happy meet you
thanks oh we are the betterments
better man emphasis on the better
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah a girl friend
i've never had a girlfriend before
either what do we do
i don't know if cave people belong in a
modern world
what's your problem big guy this place
is changing everyone
die and we really need to limit
thunks window time not now douglas the
birds are on in my day we didn't stare
at birds
we fought them let me live my life whoa
what's that
it's just a scar every mark is an
adventure and my dad doesn't even know
about this one
whoa peanut toe
you're not allowed outside the wall nope
this farm
is like your cave you're just like me
you see that wall yeah i want to jump in
we'll be back before anyone knows
you took dawn for a joyride the
betterment built the wall for a reason
that's not good
the only way to survive is if the pack
stays together
in such a dangerous world i worry about
my family's jew
what's that kill circle
today is a good day to die
hey everyone you'll never guess what i
found out sorry honey
we thought you were a predator trying to
kill us no never apologize for an
effective kill circle
hold on stop you accessorize with a
sloth i accessorize with a sloth
this is built mindset
[Music]
you